so they're going to be there as soon as
possible what should I do what should I
do so Jonathan Major's future is
officially in the hands of the jury now
after two weeks of Court closing
statements have been made by both
parties the prosecutor and the defense
and the jury is now officially
deliberating the fate of Jonathan major
they are deciding whether or not they
believe he is guilty or innocent in this
case of assault against his
ex-girlfriend Grace Jabari so in this
video we're going to go over what was
said yesterday in the closing Arguments
for both sides both for and against
Jonathan major and we'll also give you a
complete timeline of everything that
happened starting from his arrest going
all the way up to today where they are
in court right now where the jury is
deliberating now there is the chance
that they might not come to a verdict
today some might believe that he's
innocent some might believe that he's
guilty a clear conclusion might not be
reached today although it might be
reached today and this will literally
determine basically all of Jonathan
Major's future if he is found guilty he
will face up to one year in prison and
his career will essentially be destroyed
it's already taken a really big hit he's
lost jobs he's been fired from agencies
so if he has found guilty and goes to
prison he most likely will not have a
career in Hollywood anymore at least not
for a very long time but if he is found
innocent and he is innocent hopefully
the hits that his career has taken so
far won't be that bad to postpone the
trajectory iory that he was on as a
rising star and hopefully if he is found
innocent he will continue to play King
the Conqueror in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe so let's go through everything
that happened yesterday with the closing
arguments and everything that has
happened in this timeline since Jonathan
maor got arrested up until today both
Jonathan major and Grace Jabari are
accusing each other of assault Grace
Jabari says that Jonathan major
assaulted her when they were in a
private car and she read a text message
on his phone from another girl that said
wish I was kissing you right now she
then took his phone and she claims that
he was very aggressive with her and he
assaulted her to get his phone back
causing a fracture to her finger and a
blow to her head whereas Jonathan major
states that she was actually assaulting
him after she saw the text messages and
he ran away from her now Jonathan major
appeared in court every day of the trial
however he did not testify he did not
take the stand his lawyer priia Chad re
started the closing statements with his
fear of what happens when a black man in
America calls 911 came true and now
we're here you are here to end this
nightmare for Jonathan majes and as she
was speaking Jonathan majes was wiping
tears from his eyes when she was
finished speaking her and Jonathan major
hugged each other in her closing
argument she painted the accuser Grace
Jabari as a liar and stated that the
evidence doesn't line up to support a
case of assault she stated that this was
really about revenge partying and this
was not about assault but about the end
of a relationship and this was Revenge
that Grace Jabari was taking out on
Jonathan major the other day they
released video surveillance footage from
cctvs on the street showing Jonathan
major and Grace Jabari getting out of
the car Jonathan major trying to pick
her up and put her back in the car and
then Jonathan major is running away from
her Major's lawyer priia chadri states
that when she gets out of the car she is
not hurt at all she shows no signs of
just being assaulted and she's even
following Jonathan major chasing him
down the street as he tries to run away
from her she then says she then meets
three strangers and she goes to a club
and she starts partying she has a really
good time she ordered champagne and they
even claimed that she was smoking
illegally basically Jonathan Major's
team states that there is no sign at all
that she is hurt after this alleged
assault took place she is seen after
this alleged assault out partying and
having fun when Grace Jabari took the
stand she stated that she just wasn't
thinking about the pain she was thinking
about her relationship and thinking
about infidelity she said she went with
the three strangers to the club to try
and forget about the situation and she
did not notice any pain on her at the
time because she wasn't thinking about
it but majors' lawyer stated that if he
did strike her to the head like she
claimed why was there no blood there is
no blood on her outfit on her shirt
there was no blood in her hair at any
point in time and the three strangers on
the street two of them testified in
court stating that they didn't notice
any injuries on her when they saw her
and it was only until when they were at
the club she mentioned that her finger
was hurting she's also seen in the club
brushing her hair next to her ear where
she supposedly got attacked by Majors
brushing her hair in her ear like
nothing was wrong at at all majors' team
then argued about him calling the cops
himself and telling the cops that they
had gotten to an argument the night
before and they explained that he does
have a fear as a black man of cops so
they argued why would he call the cops
for Grace Jabari because he knew that
she was in trouble when he found her
passed out unconscious on the floor of
his closet in his apartment he called
the cops because he was concerned for
her so they argue why would he do that
if he is afraid of the cops and he just
assaulted her the night before before
they also say why would he tell the cops
that they had an argument the night
before if he was afraid of that as well
so they argue that it just doesn't make
any sense meanwhile more evidence was
released in court there was a
conversation recorded by Grace Jabari
where Jonathan major is scolding her
stating that he is a great man and you
can hear Grace Jabari crying in the
voice recording there were also text
messages released that showed Jonathan
major trying to dissuade Grace Jabari
from going to a hospital in 2022 with a
head injury because he said that they
would think that he did it but his
defense team argues that this was simply
him as a black man being afraid of the
cops and being afraid of being accused
which they say is now happening but
Grace jabari's team argues that she is
not a liar she has no reason to lie they
say that she chased Jonathan major down
the street because she needed closure on
what she just saw they also state that
this other evidence that was released
the voice recording of him scolding her
and the text messages stating that he
didn't want her to go to the hospital
can't be treated as isolated events and
that they show that Jonathan major was
abusive in the past even if it wasn't
physical but argue that clearly
something physical happened that
Jonathan major did not want Grace Jabari
to go to the hospital for and they
stated that Jonathan major was not
simply placing Grace Jabari back inside
of the car but he was assaulting her and
he was throwing her into the car after
the closing arguments were made the jury
went to decide the verdict the jury
began deliberating for about an hour in
which the judge then sent them home they
are picking up the case again this
morning as we speak right now the jury
is discussing whether they think
Jonathan major is innocent or guilty and
again this will determine his future and
of course when the verdict goes out or
anything else comes out we'll be sure to
do an update video so subscribe and hit
that notification Bell so you don't miss
it now as promised here is a timeline of
everything that has happened so far with
this case it started on March 25th when
Majors got arrested he is then released
with a temporary restraining order then
on March 26th charges are filed against
him three accounts of third degree
assault one count of second deegree
harassment and one count of aggravated
harassment all memers then on March 30th
Majors is the one who accuses Jabari of
assault stating he was assaulted and he
didn't assault her Major's attorney
shared screenshots with NBC News the
screenshots showed text messages from
Grace Jabari to Jonathan major stating
that she was the one who physically used
Force against him she also disavowed any
allegations that he done anything to her
and confirmed that Mr major called 911
because of her mental I condition on
April 27th the court issued a full
restraining order for Grace Jabari
against Jonathan major then on May 9th
Jonathan major made his first court
appearance via Zoom his lawyer then on
that date said that this was explicit
and implicit bias stating that it was
racial bias that permeates the criminal
justice system in which she called the
prosecution of Majors a Witch Hunt
Majors did not testify in his defense at
that time then on June 21st Jonathan
Majors went to the police to make his
own allegations against Grace Jabari
stating that Grace Jabari was the
attacker and attacked him and his lawyer
priia chadri showed them video and photo
evidence showing the attacks as well as
evidence that Majors was allegedly
victimized such as torn clothing and
from there the trial would get delayed
and delayed many different times then on
October 25th Grace Jabari was actually
arrested she turned herself in for
prosecuting following Jonathan Major's
cross complaint against her that she was
the assaulter however on October 26th
Grace jabari's case is closed the
Manhattan District Attorney's office
said that it would not prosecute her and
that the allegations against her lack
prosecutorial Merit then on November
29th the official trial began the judge
rules to not dismiss the case and then
on December 5th last week opening
statements begin the trial begins and we
started to hear the testimony of Grace
Jabari she testified that she feared
Majors but that she also worried he
would harm himself stating that he used
the Spectre of self harm to manipulate
her in which they did show text messages
in court of Jonathan major saying that
he was going to kill himself this would
go on for a week until this Wednesday
December 13th where a lot of evidence
was released this was the evidence that
we went over in the last video the CCTV
Street footage of Jonathan major shoving
Grace Jabari back into the car then him
running away from her it also showed her
meeting the three strangers on the
street after and going to the club going
to the bar and ordering champagne they
then released footage and the call that
Jonathan major made to 911 they also
released body cam footage of the police
officers who went to the apartment to
find Grace Jabari on the floor then
yesterday closing arguments were made
and the jury began to try and reach a
verdict in which they did not and were
sent home and now they are back
deliberating this morning again we'll
update you if anything happens today
they might reach a decision they might
not but either way Jonathan Major's
future is on the line so be sure to
subscribe and hit that notification Bell
so you don't miss out on any of the news
you can find us on Instagram and Twitter
as well and as always thank you all so
much for watching woof woof